the Babylonians called that Nergal the
Hindus called it Mangala the Egyptians
called it hard occur or the red one and
today we know it as the red planet for
centuries Mars has aroused our
imaginations the world's best scientists
and people everywhere have asked
themselves did life exist on Mars and
could Mars support life in the future
but what is Mars made of and could
humans ever live there this is Mars 101
Mars is the fourth planet from the Sun
while earth is 93 million miles away
from the Sun Mars is from 49 million
miles further away the combination of
added distance and the elliptical orbit
of Mars means that one year on the red
planet lasts 687 days while orbiting the
Sun much like Earth Mars has a tilt in
its axis
this means Mars gets seasons like we do
but due to its elliptical orbit some of
its seasons last longer temperatures can
reach as low as negative 284 degrees
Fahrenheit but due in part to the red
planet's distance from the Sun the
average temperature on Mars is a chilly
negative 81 degrees Fahrenheit another
key difference is gravity the
gravitational pull is much weaker on
Mars about 62% less that means that
someone who weighs a hundred pounds here
on earth would only weigh 38 pounds on
Mars Mars is about half the size of
Earth but the landmass is similar
because Mars lacks the key ingredients
in supporting life water or at least
bodies of water back in the day around
3.5 billion years ago Mars had a warm
and thick atmosphere that allowed oceans
of water to exist
nowadays Mars is a frigid and arid
desert world with no signs of life at
least on the surface but new data from
NASA's reconnaissance mission shows
evidence that liquid water does likely
flow intermittently on the red planet
another key ingredient to support life
is oxygen on earth our atmosphere is
made up of 21% oxygen and 78% nitrogen
on Mars it's hard to come by oxygen at
all
96% of Mars's atmosphere is carbon
dioxide with a population of over 7
billion people and climate change
threatening the future of our planet
Mars could be a potential future host
planet but don't buy your one-way ticket
to Mars just yet the red planet is far
from being hospitable to humans you must
first survive the one-year one-way trip
to get there once you arrive scientists
estimate that without a proper spacesuit
humans would die in minutes if not
seconds the low atmospheric pressure
would rupture your internal organs and
skin and lack of oxygen cold surface
temperatures irritating dust intense UV
radiation surface chemicals and oxidants
would ensure you die a painful death
despite all this NASA recently announced
journey to Mars an unprecedented plan
that would put humans on Mars by 2030
with proper spacesuits mind you although
we know a lot more about Mars than we
ever did scientists around the world
continue to study the planet and deploy
missions like NASA's spirit
hury ASSA t and
to better understand the planet and
maybe one day find life on it or make it
our second home